bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin pour débattre
de ces thèmes qui occupe beaucoup les
médias en ce moment on l'a vu notamment
avec cette candidature non déclarés
d'eric zemmour tout d'abord on a vu
marine le pen dont qui a présenté son
son référendum sur l'immigration
avant-hier le jour où ou gabriel attal
nous dit qu'il va réduire les visas pour
les pays du maghreb ont regardé ce qu'on
a dit gérald darmanin sur twitter
pour inciter nos voisins a accepté de
réadmettre leurs ressortissants
nous avons décidé de prendre des mesures
fortes à la demande du président de la
république
le nombre de visas délivrés par nos
consulats au maroc et en algérie va
diminuer de moitié et de 30% en tunisie
alors voilà pour les déclarations a le
même jour un bruno bonnell est-ce qu'il
faut y voir un hasard ou pas allez
avouez
que c'est pas une question d' avouer
c'est de suivre une politique était
commencée en 2018 avec la loi asile et
migrations et qui effectivement
al'inverse de nombreux gouvernements
précédents depuis des dizaines d'années
une décision forte diplomatiquement est
mis sur la table pour ces problèmes dès
les obligations de retourner dans leur
pays de ressortissants étrangers qui
sont qui sont des délinquants à côté de
ça je préfère cette solution est
d'arrêter de obsessionnellement parler
l'électoralisme à l'espèce de le climat
qui est place par certains soi-disant
candidat la présence d'un république qui
espère is le débat et qu'ils font croire
aux français que tout est simple qu'il
suffit soit de mettre des gens dans un
bateau dans un avion soit de faire un
référendum pour que on est résolu cette
question qui est une maison qui
techniquement et compliquées et
humainement quelque chose de eu de
complexe à mettre en place
si les bretons vous les régions oui oui
bien sûr moi je pense qu'il y ait un
lien évidemment entre l'affolement du
présent macron que je constate et puis
le fait que marine le pen
soit en train de dévoiler son programme
sur l'immigration son projet de
référendum et de ce point de vue
extrêmement complet et intéressant
puisqu'il ne s'agit pas comme la
personne que vous avez interrogé tout à
l'heure le disait d'adp une question
vague sur l'immigration il s'agit de
demander aux français s'ils sont
favorables au projet de loi
constitutionnelle qui a été présentée
très précisément et donc le président
macro évidemment s'aperçoit que nous
avons obtenu une victoire idéologique
c'est là que l'opinion publique est de
notre avis maintenant les migrations est
devenu un problème parce qu'elle est
trop importante et donc ils s'affolent
et hans à paulhan et bien il prend cette
décision mais qui est beaucoup trop
tardive bien sûr qu'il faut réagir face
au comportement de certains pays qui
refusent de reprendre les ressortissants
que longtemps de leur renvoyer c'est un
comportement tout à fait irrespectueux
de la france donc il faut réagir mais
pourquoi le président macron at il
attendu la fin de son mandat pour
prendre enfin un début de mesures
énergiques il n'est pas crédible et
outre je voudrais dire que il est
d'autant moins crédibles qu'ils
approuvent le projet de pacte migratoire
européen qui a été présenté par la
commission de bruxelles en septembre
2020 et qui va augmenter la pression
migratoire sur la france en obligeant
notre pays à prendre un certain quota de
migrants qui arrivent en italie et en
grèce voilà la vérité alors marine le
pen qui a porté cette idée de référendum
depuis 2010 9 c'est une proposition qui
a été reprise depuis par les prétendants
à la présidentielle à droite notamment
regarder
je veux que nous reprenions moment notre
politique migratoire
si les français me font confiance je
proposerai un référendum dès l'automne
pour que chaque année le parlement fixe
précisément la limite de personne
étrangère autorisée à entrer en france
la question de l'immigration est grave
elle va provoquer des ruptures pour la
traiter nous proposons un moratoire sur
l'immigration est un référendum pour
retrouver notre souveraineté juridique
certains domaines hagino breton le voit
bien les c'est vrai que les idées du
rassemblement national finalement
aujourd'hui sont devenus sont récupérées
en tout cas par la plupart des partis
politiques sur l'immigration est ce que
marine le pen est devenue inaudible
à valence et c'est tout l'inversé à mon
sens elle est devenue tellement audible
que les autres candidats essayent de la
copier mais moi je pense que les
français ne s'y tromperont pas et qu'ils
préféreront toujours l'original à la
copie mais non encore une fois moi je
dis nous sommes nous avons vécu une
victoire idéologique les thèmes qui sont
les nôtres l'immigration l'insécurité la
lutte contre l'islamisme ont maintenant
conquis l'opinion publique on reconnaît
que nous avions raison depuis des années
et donc marine le pen est en train de
proposer des mesures extrêmement
concrètes contrairement à d'autres
candidats très médiatisé et je ne doute
pas que les français le moment venu et
bien sauront choisir le candidat qui a
le programme le plus précis alors il ya
également la montée de l'islamisme là
aussi nos gouvernements se montrent très
très actif bruno bonnell et le fait
savoir d'ailleurs puisque le ministère
de l'intérieur publie régulièrement des
tweets un tout par jour presque regardez
nous sommes le premier gouvernement à
mener une véritable politique de lutte
contre l'islamisme depuis un an
650 établissements fermés cinq
associations dissoutes 96 lieux de culte
contrôler est-ce qu'il s'agit d'occuper
le terrain
où c'est un sujet qui est trop grave
pour simplement le traiter comme une
espèce de mouvement tactique l'échiquier
électoral c'est un sujet que nous avons
depuis le début du quinquennat a pris à
bras le corps et d'ailleurs les
résultats sont là énormément de deux
d'attentât qui aurait été déjoué il ya
des des publications qui sont interdites
il ya une lutte véritablement quelque
chose qui est très grave qui est le
terrorisme islamique là dessus il faut
pas aussi le tout mélangé il faut pas
non plus mélanger le fait que les
immigrés ont fait qu'on fait rimer jeu
entendre de mon interlocuteur on very
mais immigration insécurité terrorisme
islamiste il y à aussi heureusement
oui enfin je viens d'entendre ya
quelques secondes sur votre antenne ne
s'est pas vraiment opposé je ne suis pas
là franchement pour polémiquer sur la
ville dit simplement je dis simplement
l'émigration est un phénomène qui va
nous toucher dans les 50 prochaines
années donc quand l'europe dit il fonde
toute façon de gérer cette pression
migratoire va venir pour des raisons
climatiques poussé aux frontières de
notre continent il est important de
s'organiser et c'est dans ce sens que la
france dit bah oui je prendrai ma part
et je demande à tous les pays de prendre
leur part et c'est bien là que pour le
moment et la discussion s'est
effectivement nous avons cette pression
qui ne qui ne pourra pas s'arrêter par
un référendum - texte de loi parce que
des gens seront désespérance ou ne
pourront plus vivre physiquement donc
ils viendront ils iront par dizaines par
milliers par millions je ne sais pas
encore mais dans le siècle qui vient on
ne peut pas dire aux français il n'y
aura pas d'immigration parce que nous
l'avons décidé ça c'est un mensonge il
faut dire nous devons intégrer le fait
et heureusement ça n'a rien à voir et de
terry dynamisme et ça n'a rien à voir
avec la dureté qu'il faut avoir il à vis
des délinquants et des terroristes mais
il faut intégrer le fait que nous aurons
à gérer une intégration d'un certain
nombre de migrants parce que le monde
malheureusement est soumis à cette
pression qui s'appelle qui s'appelle le
climat le réchauffement climatique et
que donc il y aura par conséquent une
immigration qui n'est pas souhaitée par
vous et qui sera gérée et vous pensez
que l'europe parviendra à résoudre en
tout cas cette question des flux
migratoires
en tout cas ici la seule échelle qu'on
peut donner à ceux à ceux à ce problème
c'est une échelle qui en nombre de zéros
ne peut concerner qu'une agrégation pays
et un continent un pays tout seul comme
la france ne pourra pas gérer on l'a
bien vu avec la grèce ou l'italie quand
la pression était un peu plus fort c'est
devenu insupportable
moi je comprends très bien les
inquiétudes nos compatriotes et à vis de
ça je leur dit deux choses 1 tous les
immigrants ne sont pas des délinquants
terroristes de toute façon il y à cette
pression migratoire qui est autour de
nous et qu'il faudra gérer d'une manière
ou d'une autre soyons dur avec les
délinquants mais soyons lucides quant à
qu' il faudra effectivement gérer cette
crise migratoire dans les cinq entrées
des migrations qui va être central dans
les mois à venir dans cette campagne
présidentielle voyez ce qu'on dit
patrick stefanini qui risque d'ailleurs
de faire la campagne de valérie pécresse
nous n'avons pas besoin d'immigration ni
pour des raisons économiques ni pour des
raisons démographiques
malheureusement nous subissons une
immigration qui est le produit d'un
certain nombre de lois et d'accords
bilatéraux envoyez gilles lebreton est
resté fanny n'est pas d'accord avec vous
quand dites-vous un gilot breton non
mais je suis absolument stupéfait
d'entendre les propos de monsieur bonnel
qui lie à une pression migratoire c'est
certain on la constate tous mais qu'on
ne puisse rien faire face à elle je suis
en total désaccord la politique c'est
une question de volonté et nous n'allons
pas nous contenter de faire un
référendum sur un projet de loi
constitutionnelle
une fois que nous l'aurons gagner nous
allons ensuite avoir la légitimité pour
avoir une politique d'action pour lutter
contre l'immigration véritablement et
comment allons-nous faire eh bien nous
allons adopter une attitude plus dure et
plus responsable à l'égard des pays qui
laisse partir leurs ressortissants et
qu'il refuse de l'est de les récupérer
il faut bien sûr d'une part une aide au
développement c'est ce que fait
l'exécutif en l'occurrence on en
diminuant les visages ils exécutif
commence à le faire sous notre pression
est en fin de mandat donc je regrette
mais ça n'est pas crédible qu'a fait le
président macron depuis quatre ans et
demi de ce point de vue pas grand chose
il était assez angélique d'ailleurs sur
ce point quand il est arrivé au pouvoir
en maintenant et prend conscience des
réalités il essaye dans la faune mans
dans l'affolement de réagir mais il
n'est pas crédible parce qu'encore une
fois à côté des mesures qu'il annonce et
d'ailleurs qui serait destinée à être
mise en oeuvre si j'ai bien compris en
fait après son mandat donc autant dire
que c'est une promesse un petit peu
vaine et illusoire et bien
à côté de cela et bien nous nous
constatons que les euro députés de son
parti politique ici à broxeele
soutiennent le pacte migratoire européen
et je regrette mais il faudrait quand
même lire ce texte c'est un texte qui
est décrit assez bien ce que ce que nous
a dit monsieur monsieur bonnet alla
l'instant c'est à dire c'est un texte
défaitistes qui considère qu'on ne peut
pas lutter contre l'immigration et donc
l'union européenne est en train de se
mettre en ordre de marche pour
accueillir les millions de migrants il
faut pas se leurrer qui vont essayer de
venir eh bien nous ne voulons pas de ce
pacte migratoire européens et nous
constatons qu'il ya beaucoup d'espoir de
le voir d'ailleurs rejetée parce que des
pays comme la pologne et la hongrie n'en
veulent pas non plus le chancelier
autrichien il ya quelques jours vient de
faire une déclaration fracassante et
sachez que le premier ministre de ce
trio unis en ma présence à strasbourg a
clairement dit dans un discours officiel
qu'il n'approuvait pas la politique
migratoire de l'union européenne donc ça
fait déjà quatre pays qui sont en train
de se rebeller plus d'autres qui ne vont
pas tarder à venir vous voyez que la
messe n'est pas dite la submersion
migratoire n'est pas une fatalité alors
en ce qui concerne la sécurité des
français à présent on à ces
manifestations tous les jours on voit à
pantin et à aubervilliers depuis la
construction d'un mur antique rac entre
pantin et paris gérald darmanin
d'ailleurs a été interpellé au sénat a
regardé
par y déversent vers la banlieue et vers
la seine saint denis aujourd'hui pantin
aubervilliers
un certain nombre de ces de ces
problèmes et je le dis avec fermeté la
seine saint denis ne peut pas devenir le
dépotoir un bruno bonnell là aussi ma
question un mur construit à la va vite
devant les boeufs devant les caméras des
chaînes tout info difficile de ne pas y
voir une opération de communication à
cinq mois des présidentielles
et je crois que on peut reprocher
beaucoup de choses à gérald darmanin
n'est pas sa détermination à lutter
contre la drogue et que effectivement
heureusement que le gouvernement réagit
et il l'a précisé parce que moi j'étais
donc pas au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale quand est il exactement la
même question il réagit pour expliquer
que d'abord issad et prennent des
mesures de protection temporaire ce qui
a été fait des années que ça problème
perdure pourquoi et des années sous bois
bien que vous avez raison ça fait même
des années que ce soit dernière avant
même le gouvernement actuel et le ce
gouvernement a fait de la lutte contre
la drogue un de ses axes majeurs et on
avance dans cette direction avec des
mesures concrètes ya jamais eu autant de
prises de drogues de démantèlement de
réseaux malgré tout ça continue donc là
y aller pour résoudre répondra seine
saint denis moi je ne suis pas eu l'oeil
le responsable du gouvernement en charge
de ça mais j'ai entendu la réponse du
ministre qui dit un mesures d'urgence 2
essayer de trouver une solution pour
régler définitivement ce problème la
gouverner c'est pas faire de
l'information et de l'image seulement
c'est mettre en place des mesures qui
ont dès qu'ils ont des tons l étang
d'urgence des temps de d'action plus
long terme et qu'en tout cas il ya une
détermination politique à lutter contre
la drogue là dessus je pense pas qu'on
peut reprocher depuis le début de sorman
de son mandat ni rythme annuel macro ni
hadji darmana de ne pas être déterminée
dans la lutte contre ce fléau les
réactions aussi le breton il nous reste
quelques minutes oui c'est cette affaire
du crack a été extrêmement mal gérée à
paris on se contente de déplacer le
problème en refile la patate chaude
quartiers voisins ont construit un mur
en plus pour essayer de protéger les
habitants fin c'est surréaliste de dents
dans quel pays vit-on ce n'est pas une
façon convenable il digne de traiter le
problème ces toxicomanes il faut les
hospitalisé d'office voilà c'est la
solution qui est tout à fait prévu par
le droit français il faut oser à prendre
ce qu'ils sont des migrants illégaux et
y en a beaucoup parmi ceux là et bien
doivent te est également être refoulés
vers leur pays et puis enfin lutter
contre la drogue ça nécessite aussi une
action et la tour le tirage des
toxicomanes mais c'est ce que j'ai dit
l'hospitalisation d'office c'est bien
paul et pour les soigner 1 mais comme
ils ne veulent pas être hospitalisés de
leur plein gré eh bien on a cette
procédure qu'on peut utiliser lorsqu'il
y a mise en danger d'autrui et ce qui
est le cas de toute évidence dans cette
affaire voilà donc là aussi c'est encore
une question de volonté politique
si on veut prendre le problème à bras le
corps on le peut et c'est ce qu'on fera
merci beaucoup c'est la fin de ce débat
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venu en direct débattre sur notre
antenne merci